[Music]
you're my only daughter
if i say that you should be married then
married you should be
where is the lady catherine i've come
here to propose marriage a man has come
and asked me by name you cannot mean our
lady catholic she's a vile creature some
say she has a third ear she does have
you seen this third ear i've seen it
where back of her neck
what is it functional
i'm not interested in meeting him not
any man with his intention
would i choose to die rather than be
forced to marry i do not think either
option appealing or fair
i cheer for you birdie i fear for you
i am thank thankful
very cunning most girls are they are not
giving you credit for it i do think
she's come down with something she's got
a little little um little little little
bit of i think there's a little bit of
pox going around the village
parks oh no i mean it's not the village
[Music]
you must learn how to harness them you
don't get to decide who we are where we
go how much we cost like we're just
things we're not things with people and
we can think and we can hear we can feel
but we are here
i wish i could help every girl in the
world
knowing your own story will be your
salvation
but for now
i am enough
[Music]
you